i said to you it's going to be complex
right
it's going to be this kind of complex
all right
now remember if you see if you think you
see what's going wrong
keep it to yourself hold on to your hats
the square root of negative one uh one
of the things we know about square roots
is that you can rewrite them
without the square root times you can
use index notation right
okay do you remember why we can use
index notation like how does it work
why is it that um two
the square root of two is equal to to
the power of half like did we just
did people just decide i would like it
to be a half what's the reason yeah
is it because they're inverse
yes kind of kind of there's a there's a
more
uh there's a simpler reason to it though
that doesn't have to appeal to any fancy
language that we've learned anyone
remember how did you draw this yeah
okay cool yeah i will go we'll go we'll
go with that
um if i say just think about your own
sorry simpler example
think about your index laws okay so if i
go 2 cubed
times 2 to the 5 i'm multiplying so what
do i do to the indices
i add them very good to the end okay so
now what you consider is what happens
when it's a fraction right
so if i have two to the half times two
to the half
right well you add them don't you so
half plus half
gives you one just two so in other words
whatever this number is when you
multiply it by itself
you get 2. and we have a name for that
number it's the square root of 2.
so far so good so i'm going to rewrite
this guy
negative 1 to the power of a half so far
so good
so you've got to do things like this
because you've got to question
everything right
all right now um let's let's let's go
back to u7 let's go back to u7 okay
i want us to simplify some fractions
okay let's let's see how we go
can you simplify that what's that equal
to
three over five can you simplify this
that's one over three okay can you
simplify this that's a half
good that's important to me because
that's a half so i can write this can't
i
yeah so far so good
i don't know you all agreed all good
it's just fractions guys come on
just fractions right all right now i'm
going to keep going i'm going to keep
going
um back to the index laws back to the
index laws
uh if i had something like 3 squared
3 squared to the power of
3. three squared to the power of three
okay this is a different thing to this
right what do i do to these indices i
multiply them
why do i multiply them
it's uh yeah okay all right
so so it's nine cubed which is actually
uh
i don't know that's a really big number
okay uh 729.
you can illustrate it in a simple way
though cube just means
two or three times yes one time
two times three times right look
two two two two times three that's
that's six
okay so if this index law works i can
use it here
connor minus one squared
there's one part pair of
a quarter
why are you shaking your heads a bit you
all agreed here and then you're like no
doing something shifty you know so far
i think it looks okay you may disagree
okay tell me everyone minus one squared
one yes oh no
the number that we decided what this
meant before
right this is some number where you
multiply by itself four times and you
get one
that sounds to me like it's one
right
if i wanted to i could go back to here i
could just i could square both sides and
i can get back to this guy if that if
that wasn't bad enough for you
okay so fallacy
number three